بعض المرشحين في الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه لم يفوز فقط بل كسروا بعض
الحواجز ودخلوا التاريخ الامريكي نبدا من
ولايه دلموند التي ولاول مره ترسل امراه
وهي بكابلنت كممثله بمجلس النواب ولايه
بنسلفانيا بدورها اختارت لاول مره سيده من
اصول افريقيه كعضو بمجلس النواب وهي نائبه
سمرلي نبقى مع الحالات الاولى ولايه
ايلينوي سترسل لمجلس النواب لاول مره سيده
من اصول اللاتينيه هي داليا راميز وحلم
مشابهه لكن في مجلس الشيوخ ولايه الامامه
او صلاه كيتي للمجلس لاول مره في تاريخ
الولايه الى الجنوب قليلا اختارت ولايات
اركانسون امراه كحاكمه لها وهي سيره هاكبي
ساندرس المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض في عهد
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب امراه اخرى
دخلت تاريخ ولايتها كاول حاكمه لها هي كيف
هوكول الحاكمه الحاليه للولايه لكنها وصلت
بالتعيين ويوم امس اصبحت الحاكمه المنتخب
الان ننتقل الى الفئات العمريه ماكس
والفروست دخل تاريخ الكونجرس كاسغر عضو
يصل المجلس في الخامسه والعشرين من عمره
وفي المقابل اعادت ولايات ايوان انتخابات
عضوي مجلس الشيوخ جروسلي مره اخرى
السيناتور ان تخذ لاول مره عام 81 من
القرن الماضي ويبلغ من العمر الان 89 عاما
لكن جرسلي لن يكون اكبر اعضاء المجلس عمرا
اثناء فتره خدته الرقم القياسي مسجل حتى
اللحظه باسم سنتر ترامب من ساوث كايرو
لاين الذي وصل لعمر 100 عام و29 يوما
اثناء عمله بمجلس الشيوخ